after watching the latest episode of The
Last of Us there's truly only one man
capable of capturing my emotions to me
this situation is a blood-soaked
nightmarish hellscape I'm not interested
in caring about people there's a sign at
Ramset Park that says do not drink the
sprinkler water so I made some tea with
it and now I have an infection yes I
can't believe they got Ron Swanson to
play bill in this absolutely
heart-wrenching episode which had me
questioning
am I gay in this video we'll be taking a
deep dive into episode 3 its connection
to the game lore Easter eggs and a whole
lot more and with that let's get into it
but before you do be sure to like And
subscribe I may not always cover the
shows you watch but when I do it's
fantastic we open 10 miles west of
Boston likely a day after Tess had one
of the creepiest makeout sessions
she sacrificed herself so that Joel and
Ellie could escape the infected at the
Capitol building it's only been about
two days since Joel fractured his hand
while turning this fedra agent's face
into a pile of goo he dips his hand in
the water to retrieve Stones which he
piles on top of one another to create
this Cairn Cairns or stone stacking has
held multiple meanings throughout
history commonly used as Trail markers
or Barrel mounds and here I think it's
the latter Tess was Jules Rock she
grounded him and this small Act is a way
of remembering her this shot here is one
of my favorites in the episode as it
displays three symbols of Joel's past
trauma one the bloody hand the killing
of the federal agent to the Cairn Tess's
death and three Sarah's watch a constant
reminder of his daughter's death this is
all interspersed with the director's
decision to frame Joel in these Forest
POV shots suggesting that even during
these tranquil moments someone could
always be watching it seems Joel and
Ellie have spent the night in the woods
Joel even gave Ellie his jacket for
warmth in the game Ellie says she's
never even walked through the woods
before you mean the woods yeah
cool got the big elephant in the forest
is Tessa's death if you remember last
episode he simply left Ellie and walked
away after she died he didn't say a word
Joel has learned to bottle his emotions
this is why he doesn't want to talk to
Ellie about his past just like he
skirted her questions in episode 2 nor
why he doesn't bring up Tessa's death
the same is true in the game here's how
this thing's gonna play out
you don't bring up Tess
ever matter of fact we just keep our
histories to ourselves this is almost
identical to the three rules Joel gives
Ellie near the end of the episode rule
one you don't bring up tests ever
matter of fact we can just keep our
histories to ourselves rule two don't
tell anyone about your condition and
Rule 3 do what he says when he says it
Daddy chill
what the hell is even that fun fact in
the game version this conversation
happens before they reach Bill while in
the show it happens right after they
leave his place but Ellie isn't going to
take this [__] from Joel saying so don't
blame me for something that isn't my
fault it was Joel's choice to take on
this Mission he and Tess knew the risks
at the end of episode 2 tests Joel to
take Ellie to Bill and franks in the
hopes they'll take her in in the game
version she tells him to take her to
Tommy Bill and Frank were the BNF
markings and Joel Smuggler code which
Ellie easily deciphered in episode 1.
later in the episode we'll actually see
that it was Frank who suggested to test
that they use codes over the radio Ellie
asked if Bill and Frank are nice to
which Joel says Frank is as we'll soon
meet Bill will know exactly why Joel
answered this way Ellie also takes
notice of Joel's gun in episode 2 she
wanted one but was relegated to only
throwing chicken sandwiches can I have a
gun absolutely not okay geez it's fine
sandwich in the game she wants a gun too
what
what I need a gun
no you don't it's even hinted at in the
show that this smaller gun here might
have once belonged to Bill as we'll
later find out Frank sold one of Bill's
smaller guns to Tess and Joel in
exchange for strawberry seeds at
Cumberland Farms an abandoned gas
station where Joel left a stash of
supplies several years prior Ellie finds
an old arcade version of Mortal Kombat 2
stating she had a friend who knew
everything about it this is a reference
to Riley who was briefly mentioned in
episode 1 by Marlene terrorist
was Riley a terrorist
we haven't yet seen her in the show but
in the season ahead trailer we get a
brief glimpse of her on this Carousel a
nod to the events of The Last of Us DLC
titled left behind in the game they
stumble across an arcade and it's not
Mortal Kombat 2 but a game called the
turning it also makes an appearance at
the pizza and sub restaurant in Lincoln
in The Last of Us Part One I had a
friend that knew everything about this
game unfortunately no cool Molina kills
Molina wins bonus points if you caught
the Lifesavers stand in the background a
fun metaphor for Joel and Ellie being
each other's Lifesaver and extra points
if you caught the safe code on the wall
in the game safe codes are littered all
over the place which lead to valuable
safes while Joel tries to find the
supplies he stashed years ago Ellie has
the insanely smart idea to venture into
the Creepy Hidden basement and I'm not
sure what's scarier for the men out
there on this scene the crushed infected
or a box of Tampax Pearl I also love the
inclusion of lockers in the background
of this set you know I'd be there
checking all these for extra supplies
Ellie is surprisingly curious around
this infected even using her switchblade
the one passed down to her by her mother
to cut into its skin the layers
underneath are reminiscent of those
conducted on the woman in Jakarta 20
years ago the tissue definitely doesn't
look normal she stabs the infected
killing it and doesn't even tell Joel
back up top into her surprise Joel
leaves his rifle claiming that carrying
it with so little ammo essentially makes
it useless as they continue their
Journey they come across a downed plane
in episode 1 we saw just how dangerous
it could be flying as soon as the
infection spread and I thought flying
Delta was bad Ellie thinks it's so cool
that Joel once flew in one of these
things and it really puts into
perspective all the things we take for
granted even things as simple as a hot
shower or strawberries for her entire
life Ellie has grown up in ephedra
orphanage thus her education
conveniently left out how the government
failed to prevent the pandemic in the
first place this is the writers taking a
jab at our own government's failure to
respond to covid-19 with Ellie even
asking if the virus started by a monkey
much like the theory out there that
kovid started with infected bats the
most common theory is that this fungal
infection spread via tainted flower
which quickly spread around the world
Joel even makes reference to pancake mix
what Sarah was gonna make her dad on his
birthday talk about dodging a bullet on
their way Joel is unable to steer Ellie
away from a series of unmarked Graves
these are the bones of innocent families
taken from the nearby town of Lincoln
and shot to death when there was no more
room in the quarantine zones these
civilians were killed because dead
people don't get infected the game does
not make mention of these roundups
rather stating see some places got a
heads up before the infection showed up
most didn't there's this great
transition of the clothing of a mother
and child as we flash back 20 years to
September 30th 2003 roughly four days
after the events we saw in Austin Texas
in episode 1. it's a bit ironic that we
see the swaying of an American flag as
these people lose their freedoms as
we'll see in town Lincoln is under a
mandatory evacuation where everyone must
be shipped off similar signs can be seen
in the game it's also ironic that the
town is named after a President Who
espoused Freedom yet everyone here is
being shipped away against their will
bill here has a hidden basement within a
basement where he keeps a close watch of
his property via security cameras my
idea of a perfect government is one guy
who sits in a small room at a desk and
the only thing he's allowed to decide is
who to Nuke he's a paranoid conspiracy
theory prepper or as he likes to call
himself a survivalist it's funny that
people who do this nowadays are
considered a bit weird but Ellie refers
to Bill as a genius the basement is
Bill's Armory where he has a stash of
weapons and supplies including a
workbench where we all know you can
upgrade your weapons Bill comes out
wearing a gas mask which he also wears
the first time we see him in the game I
also love how his home has this sign
that says come in the evening or come in
the morning come unexpected or come
without warning which is just the
complete opposite of who bill is as a
character unlike the town of Lincoln in
the game which is more densely populated
the show's Lincoln is more akin to a
quaint rural suburb Bill wastes no time
stocking up on gasoline collecting
supplies and of course Gathering the
most important thing booze he also has a
knack for anything technical being able
to connect the gas pipeline to his place
and operating this large generator of
course no town can be safe without the
appropriate electrified fence trap pits
and who can forget flamethrowers in fact
his nightly entertainment is watching as
these traps kill and infected
oh he even says it doesn't get old as if
this is a regular occurrence for him we
see Joel encounter several of Bill's
traps in the game and if you're curious
what Bill's fence looks like in the game
here it is as Bill finishes his setup
Queen's 1968 song White Room plays and
if we remember the Smuggler's code found
in Joel's apartment a 60 song means
there's nothing and Bill does have
nothing or should I say no one he's all
alone which mimicked the song Sad lyrics
I'll wait in this place where the Sun
never shines this is all to change four
years later with the introduction of
Frank in Bill's bunker we get a quick
shot of a don't tread on me flag also
known as the godson flag often used as a
symbol of distrust or Defiance against
Authority and the government when his
alarm alerts him to one of his traps
going off we meet Frank a man who is
only seen dead in the game and what's
about to transpire between these two
varies wildly from game to show Frank
was on his way to the Boston quarantine
Zone after the Baltimore qz was
completely destroyed he started with 10
people but now he's the only one left of
course bill is distrustful he has no
idea who this guy is and if he lets him
go he could tell others then every bum
you talk to about it is going to show up
here looking for a free lunch
and this is not an Arby's
[Music]
in the game we find a body of a dead
Smuggler who has a note that says your
contact is a dude named Frank and that
he wants into the Boston qz this dead
guy here was waiting for Frank but Frank
never showed up I'll get into why that
is in the game version in a bit but
something inside Bill compels him to
take Frank in and after a quick check to
make sure he's not infected using the
same type of scanner fedra uses no less
he's treated to a hot shower and warm
meal we also get our first clue that
bill may be gay he's a bit awkward and
this awkwardness may stem from his
repressed sexuality as he'll later tell
Frank he's never been with a man the
game simply refers to Bill and Frank as
partners but as we'll soon see their
relationship pans out quite differently
in the show version check out Bill's
house it's filled with dust and antiques
drab colors and old photos it's of a
world that used to be compare this to
the house we see near the end of the
episode with bright flowers colors
paintings and warmth Frank has brought
not only this change to Bill's home but
to Bill himself bill has prepared rabbit
and every time I hear rabbit with the
lust of us I always think of
the cutest [__]
fancier that Frank is kind of testing
the waters here with Bill's sexuality
stating that he does indeed look like a
man who knows what wine to pair with
rabbit I'm uh I'm getting an extremely
gay Vibe later when Bill plays Linda
ronstadt's long long time coincidentally
the name of this episode he asks him who
the girl in the song is he's talking
about there is no girl because Bill is
gay they share a kiss and Frank has to
remind bill that he hasn't even told him
what his name is now you may have also
wondered if there's any significance to
Bill's tattoos those are actually actor
Nick offerman's real tattoo so I think
it's a safe bet to say no now Frank
wants to say a few more days and those
few days turn into three years as we
fast forward to 2010. Bill and Frank are
in the midst of a fight where stubborn
bill doesn't want Frank to use up their
supplies to spruce up their surroundings
it's history too let him love it the way
he wants to this is my street too just
certainly love it the way I want to this
is the same line he says near the end of
the episode don't love me the way I want
you to part of sprucing up this town is
to make it welcoming to friends
something bill is extremely against but
it's Frank who pushes bill out of his
shell he's even been secretly chatting
with someone over the radio who will
later find out his tests yes anything is
possible in flashbacks as we get to see
anatore back again as Tess in the game
Bill asks why Tess isn't with him but
Joel doesn't tell him that she's dead we
also get these little fun bits of
information like this paper written by
Bill or Frank to collect more pills and
it mentions of a meet up with Tess so
it's clear there's this Smuggler
connection between these two parties
over a quaint lunch where Joel has a gun
constantly pointed at him Tess Frank
bill and Joel discuss the possibility of
working together Bill and Frank have
supplies Joel and tessneed and vice
versa bill is still against this saying
that they're completely self-sufficient
but that isn't true Joel notes that his
fence will need to be replaced in the
next year and he could get Bill some
aluminum spools that could last them a
lifetime not to mention the qz has
access to books medicine and machine
parts this medicine will actually come
into play later on according to the
show's timeline Tess and Joel are in
Boston and working together by 2010.
their relationship status is also called
into question when Joel can't seem to
find the right words when referring to
him and Tess but as we'll see in the
letter near the end of the episode it's
clear Bill and Frank knew what they were
or should I say could be in my episode 2
breakdown I theorized from this line I
never ask you for anything not to feel
the way I felt that test wanted more
from Joel but because he was so closed
off he could never commit to anyone in
The Last of Us podcast we learned that
they even wrote a completely different
intro for episode 2 in which we see what
happened to Tess's family Tess had a kid
she had a husband and she had a son they
were infected she killed her husband but
she could not kill the sun Tess and
Joel's relationship is also brought up
by Bill in the game where he says
like might be trouble in Paradise as
they leave Lincoln it looks to me like
Frank gives Tess a lavender top and some
jeans I wonder if it's the same shirt
we'll see her wear in episodes one and
two Joel also gives Bill a word of
warning fedra in infected aren't what he
should be worried about it's these
roaming bands of Raiders who will come
at night and make quick work of his
fence and protections perhaps Joel
doesn't know the full extent of Bill's
defenses as we'll later see Raiders
killed by flamethrowers and defense's
electricity three years later in 2013 a
bill struggles to keep up with Frank I
got something to show you you mean a
penis not that he surprised him with
strawberries yet another example of
something so simple we take for granted
nowadays Bill tells him that he was
never afraid until he showed up that's
because Bill now has something afraid of
losing that night a band of Raiders
descend on the town Frank searches for
Bill and takes out a pistol from the
dresser the same pistol Ellie will later
find and keep hidden from Joel bill is
shot in the melee and Frank rushes him
back to take care of his wound Bill
thinks he's a goner and tells Frank to
call Joel even Bill sees Joel as this
protector type character fortunately
Bill survives and the defense was strong
enough to ward off the Raiders fast
forward 10 years to 2023 the same year
the main events of the show take place
Frank needs a wheelchair to get around
and is taken to painting we'll see one
which looks like a bowl of strawberries
and lots of paintings of carrots which
were the first crops Bill grew this
painting looks like the first half was
painted when Frank still had his full
motor function while the other half
looks as though he attempted painting it
when he lost it unfortunately this is
one motor Bill can't fix it's never
explained in the show what illness Frank
has just that it was incurable even
before the pandemic hit so my best guess
here is some form of cancer we'll see
him here in this yellow shirt yellow
just like in episode 2 often used to
convey sickness life for Frank is tough
he can only consume liquids and has to
be helped everywhere he goes so so Frank
asked bill for one last good day give me
one more good day it's a heart-wrenching
sequence as we see the two enjoy their
last day and perform their own wedding
bill even makes him rabbit paired with
the same wine they had the first day
they met the plan was to have Frank
drink wine mixed with a lethal dose of
medication but unbeknownst to him bill
has done the same with his his entire
life bill has had no purpose but as he
later tells Frank and you were my
purpose losing the one thing that has
kept his life worth living was too much
for bill so he makes the choice to join
him with only a few minutes before the
pills kick in Bill Wheels Frank into the
room at the end of the hall and locks
the door we'll see them slowly shift out
of focus as their lives cut to Black
just like it does in the show we fast
forward what is likely a few weeks after
Bill and Frank's death we know this from
the rotting food and the fact that
Bill's radio has defaulted to an 80s
playlist which is only supposed to
happen if bill hasn't reset the
countdown which he's supposed to do 2
every few weeks we also know 80s music
equals trouble we heard this chime on
Joel's radio at the end of episode 1.
here we can see the Lincoln town sign
and compared to the one from the game
Joel knows the code to the front gate
likely because he had been working with
Bill and Frank for the past 13 years the
first sign that something is out of the
ordinary are the Dead flowers outside
the home and inside we can see these
candles have burned to the bottom it's
not too long after Ellie finds the
letter addressed to whomever but
probably Joel and the crushed pill bag
that they put two and two together I
found Bill's note to be a message of
Hope for Joel like Joel Bill hated the
world but Bill found a person worth
saving he found his purpose in
protecting them if Joel can find that
person perhaps he too can find the peace
and happiness that makes life worth
living bill alludes that this person is
Tess for Joel and it's a bit tough to
make out but we can see the words and
she decide you've recommend pairing and
the name of a wine I got the Feeling
here that Bill had kind of set aside
some wine if Tess and Joel would become
a thing which is even more tragic
considering what happened to her last
episode Joel crumples up the letter
similar to how Bill crumpled up Frank's
letter in the game and for the first
time since losing his daughter I got the
feeling that maybe just maybe Joel might
show some emotion but he once again
bottles it up bill has bequeathed to
Joel his truck which is the same blue
Chevy found in the game along without
any supplies he wants but with Bill and
Frank gone what does Joel do with Ellie
in the game the whole purpose of
visiting bill is not to dump Ellie off
to him but to get a car in the game
version Bill owls Joel big time for a
series of unknown reasons and favors he
has to see her bite mark one last time
still perhaps hesitant that she is
legitimately immune then he devises a
plan to travel out to Wyoming to see his
brother Tommy it's kind of like killing
two birds with one stone Joel's whole
reason for taking on this mission was to
get a battery to find his brother but at
the same time Tommy is a former Firefly
and may know where this supposed Firefly
Camp filled with doctors is remember
that Marlene's plan was to have her
Squadron of fireflies pick Ellie up at
the Capitol building and take her to
this secret Camp while waiting for the
battery to charge Ellie finds this palm
tree shirt which is the same shirt we
see her wearing when we're first
introduced to her in the game and while
Joel takes a shower Ellie hides the gun
she found in this desk undoubtedly to
play a role later in the season in the
truck Ellie remarks that it's her first
time in one she doesn't even know how to
put on a seatbelt she remarks that it's
like a spaceship perhaps foreshadowing
the birthday present Joel gets her when
he takes her to the museum in The Last
of Us Part 2. now there is a tape in
this scene here but it's a spaceship
countdown not like the tape Ellie finds
in the glove compartment which states
mix for Bill obviously a gift Frank gave
bill which contains the song they played
the first time they met Linda ronstad's
long long time its lyrics include love
is full of loss who knows the cost as we
Dolly back to reveal the final shot of
that open window Bill said he'd keep
open while this ending is simultaneously
beautiful and tragic the same can't be
said for the game's version which takes
a a different approach to the tale of
Bill and Frank in the game Joel and
Ellie actually meet with Bill with Joel
even getting caught in one of his traps
the first time we meet him Bill and
Frank were Partners but went their
separate ways Once Upon a Time
I had somebody that I cared about
partner
somebody I had to look after
and in this world that sort of shit's
good for one thing get you killed and it
looks like Frank had enough a bill
wanted to be smuggled into Boston but
was bit along the way we'll later see
him having hung himself rather than turn
into one of the infected just like Joel
received a letter the game's version has
one too but it's not for Joel it's for
Bill consider it Frank's suicide note it
goes on to describe something that
couldn't be further than the type of
relationship Bill and Frank had in the
show in it Frank states that he left
town because he hated Bill's guts due to
him being stuck in his ways Frank wanted
more to life and couldn't get it by
staying there with him so in the end the
risk of getting killed was better than
spending one more day with bill the bill
segment of the game has this whole
sequence which takes place at a
runner-infested school it's there we get
our first glimpse of a bloater something
that's already been hinted at in the
show so there aren't super infected they
just blowed fungus spores on you no word
yet if this segment has been cut
entirely or if we'll see it shifted
around to a different episode we know
that this is possible considering the
hotel Lobby scene from episode 2 doesn't
happen until later on in the game both
versions however end relatively the same
Joel and Ellie leave Lincoln with a
truck but in the game version Ellie
knows how to drive one and they drop off
Bill near the end of town his fate in
the game Universe remains unclear
although you gotta hand it to the guy
he's a great Gift Giver handing over a
gas siphon to Joel as a parting gift but
now I hand it over to you what did you
think of this week's controversial
episode I want to hear your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
I'm not interested in caring about
people
foreign